20-17 was filled with cinematic wins
from horror hits like get out and it to
the continued superhero domination of
Logan Wonder Woman and thor ragnarok to
indie favorites like baby driver and the
big sick but not every movie that made
way to the silver screen this year has
seen such success here are some of the
biggest thinkers Hollywood produced in
2017 the book of Henry after the
positive critical reception of safety
not guaranteed and the financial success
of Jurassic world director Colin
Trevorrow made a serious misstep of the
book of Henry sure his third feature has
a fantastic poster but the film itself
was widely dissed and dismissed the pic
stars Jaden Lieber her as the title
character and insanely intelligent
eleven-year-old who spends his days
inventing Rube Goldberg machines
investing in the stock market and taking
care of his adorable brother Henry is so
smart as to be obnoxious constantly
correcting every adult around them from
doctors to school principals Hank it's
actually Henry I think you'd be able to
retain at least one simple name
somewhere beyond that haircut this
prompted critics a panda would be here
over smug and unlikable even as he tries
to rescue his neighbor from being abused
by a police commissioner stepdad by way
of an elaborate Sassa nation plots once
his own life reaches a point of peril
it's hard to care about him anymore wish
upon when wish upon hit theaters in July
it faced some steep box-office
competition for more of the Planet of
the Apes but that was the least of this
film's problems instead it was the
movies ridiculous plot line that sunk
any interest in the film it followed a
high school outcast named Claire who
came into possession of a mysterious box
has been possessed by a demon who will
grant her wishes but takes a life in
return for her heart's desires while the
obvious way to beat this box is to
simply stop wishing Claire just can't
get enough and keeps wishing for things
that are hardly worth the cost critics
hated the derivative plots and a
superficial centerpiece and the film
barely recouped its modest budget the
house you can hire all the comedian's
you want but if you don't have a solid
script then your movie won't get any
laughs that was a problem with the house
the latest from Andrew J Cohen and
Brenda
brien of neighbors and mike and dave
knee wedding dates Fame although the
house boasts the talents of Will Ferrell
and Amy Poehler instead of giving them a
strong screenplay to work with which we
were kind of counting on it leans almost
exclusively on their improv skills the
so-called comedy revolves around a pair
of parents who open a casino in their
friend's house to raise tuition money
for their daughter but things get wildly
out of control soon the two become
subordinate mobsters using drugs and
chopping off fingers while it seems like
this wacky premise could lead to some
good gags most of the jokes failed to
land with critics or those few audience
members who bothered to watch a family
man Gerard Butler was not a good year
thanks Tim parts of this movie the plot
for a family man follows his ruthless
businessman character who ignores his
poor children as he tries to win the
favor of his outgoing employer and
outmaneuver his office rival to become
the new boss all while drinking a lot of
redbull of course things get complicated
when his kid is diagnosed with leukemia
forcing our hero to choose between a son
and his job all in all a family man is a
predictable story that tries to jerk a
few tears as Gerard Butler becomes a
good dad but critics found it hard to
relate or root for his character the
emoji movie you might think a movie
featuring Patrick Stewart as a walking
talking piece of poop would at least be
worth watching as a gag but the emoji
movie is such a soulless slug it
deprives you of even that simple
pleasure it's a movie that's supposedly
about being true to yourself but really
it's just a big commercial for Spotify
and candy crush a lot of people scoffed
at the idea of this movie when it was
first announced and rightfully so the
film was obliterated by critics even
though it still turned a profit at the
box office
the last face there's no denying Sean
Penn is a talented filmmaker but even
the very best directors come up with a
bomb now and then unfortunately the last
face is so bad that when it played at
can the audience started heckling the
movie pretty much as soon as it started
rolling the last face takes place in
countries like Sierra Leone Liberia and
Sudan but for a film set in Africa it's
kind of weird that all the black people
are relegated to playing background
roles or mutilated corpses instead the
movie centers on beautiful white people
falling in love which did not play well
to its audience of the
of all or earn wide-release as a result
the nut job - nutty by Nature the nut
job wasn't exactly what you'd call a
masterpiece but it made enough money to
prompt a sequel nutty by nature follows
its woodland stars after they're forced
to return to the wild
at which point our furry friends led by
surly move into the local city park
unfortunately the mayor plans on
chopping down the trees and turning the
area into a theme park and he hires a
group of exterminators to deal with the
rodents forcing the critters to fight
back critics panned the pig for being
boring and unimaginative and earn less
than half the revenue of its predecessor
due to audience disinterest The Dark
Tower Hollywood has tried to adapt
Stephen King's The Dark Tower series for
years and now after years of waiting
fans of the novel can finally see Roland
chute with his mind on the big screen
unfortunately the movie was absolutely
awful and failed to capture any of the
magic that made the book so beloved The
Dark Tower stars Eva Salva as a
gunslinger dedicated to protecting the
titular Tower and defending
eleven-year-old Jake from the man in
black Dark Tower should have been a slam
dunk but instead of being as original
and exhilarating as the books the movie
was derided as generic action fare which
is everything Kings version was not
Flatliners when the original Flatliners
hit theaters in 1990 it made a pretty
penny at the box office but still failed
to impress many critics compared to this
year sudo sequel though the original
feels like an absolute masterpiece of
horror the film follows a group of med
students experimenting with life after
life their tests involved taking some
heavy-duty drugs stopping their hearts
for a minute or two and checking out the
other side before being resuscitated
naturally messing around with the
afterlife has serious consequences but
when our heroes start experiencing some
spooky visions the film devolves into
jump-scare the movie critics called out
the film's a lack of suspense foolish
characters and lacking visuals leading
many to waste a property would have just
stayed dead gyeo storm when the trailer
for Geo storm first hit everybody knew
we were in for something brainless but
audiences had their fingers crossed for
some campy fun
unfortunately the film had almost no
redeeming qualities and got laughed out
of the theaters the film followed a man
to save a series of satellites that
protect the world from apocalyptic
weather events after somebody sabotages
the system with catastrophes breaking
out across the globe there's a lots of
visual flair in play but those action
scenes are few and far between
interrupted by long segments of boring
flat characters staring at a bunch of
screens the snowman on paper the snowman
should have been awesome it stars as
several formidable thespians and was
directed by Tomas Alfredson
director of Let The Right One In and
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy but despite
all that talent the film is a bloody
mess based on the novel by Jo Nesbo the
Snowman follows an alcoholic detective
who chases a psycho with a thing for
building snowmen
unfortunately the thrills are undone by
a slew of messy subplots over-the-top
music subpar performances and a bunch of
supposedly freaky Frosty's that really
are not frightening it also didn't help
that the Snowman had one of the worst
and most mean worthy marketing campaigns
in recent history give you all the tools
instead of being scary the movie ended
up arriving as one of the year's most
unintentionally funny movies but only
after being plowed by critics get it
Jesus as bad as the movie thanks for
watching click the link for the rest of
2017 s worst movies and check out all
this other stuff we know you're loved
too
[Applause]